campaigning for a seat in the eu
parliament means getting out and talking
to the voters and in slovenia there are
lots of potential voters at the market
at age 26 nesi capolich is the youngest
candidate for the center-right sls party
she's out to mobilize the young vote but
there aren't many young people at the
farmer's market
strolling through town and the
marketplaces
i see mostly older people
you generally meet the younger ones
elsewhere but it's hard to reach them
in sweden amelia anish daughter has got
an early start to carlskrona where she
studies digital communications so when
she talks about data security in the eu
she's in her element
amelia is 27 and currently the youngest
member of the european parliament
but she knows more about internet issues
than any of the others
i try to create better relationships
between um policy and technology and how
are we influenced by technologies what
is the correct policy to have with
respect to to that influence
so the data protection amelia represents
sweden's pirate party the internet is an
important issue in sweden and to the
pirates no wonder the party originated
here
probably because i work with digital
media here
it's
i don't really mind handing a lot of
data over but at the same time it's nice
to know what happens with it just to
sort of have a
an overview
in sweden the internet is a jobs
provider nine out of ten communication
students will find a job right after
graduation
in slovenia young people are lucky to
find any job at all especially during
the european debt crisis
nezi capolich has been working for years
at the youth club in her hometown and
knows the problems young people face
unemployment and dependence upon parents
is a problem for young people all over
europe but unfortunately it's at its
worst in slovenia young people have a
hard time getting on their feet here
because there just aren't any jobs
young slovenians tend to see politics as
nothing but corrupt officials vying for
money and power hardly any other
profession has as bad an image here
public interest in the european
parliamentary elections is low
i don't really
i don't like politics
so i don't pay much attention to that
the eu has to start doing something
about this disenchantment with politics
or in 10 to 15 years we're not going to
have any active citizens left whether in
slovenia or elsewhere the eu can't work
on that basis
amelia drops by a school in renew the
kids start learning the basics of
programming in the early grades right
along with their parents
as networked as amelia may be she
doesn't connect with children well soon
she finds a quiet corner where she can
write emails
visits an exhibition on lace making a
slovenian tradition that many children
here learn early on
this is the candidate's fourth stop for
the day but she's genuinely interested
she's a good communicator
she originally studied law but now she
wants to go into politics even though
she knows her chances with this party
are small
the year before she served as wine queen
she learned to keep a tight schedule
without losing her
concentration been so active that lots
of people have gotten to know me they've
seen that i have talent and i can do
something positive for our country
amelia takes a different approach
late in the evening she meets with other
activists to organize a poster campaign
the pirates don't seem to have much wind
in their sails yet
all political elections are always won
by well i mean
hard work but
also a fair bit of luck so
i'm very lucky fortunately so we'll see
how how far that gets me
on her road to the european parliament
nezika pavlich has to contend with
slovenia's voter apathy and
disillusionment with the eu
but she has high hopes
of course it'd be wonderful for me to
become a member of the eu parliament i'm
still young who knows maybe the dream
will come true
by the time amelia sets off to put up
her posters it's late at night
but even if she wins re-election to the
european parliament she says it won't
mean she's joined the political
establishment